mais pour parler nous sommes avec cécile
riz la députée la république en marche
troisième circonscription du val d'oise
jean frédéric poisson président du parti
via la voix du peuple
stéphane reinig holt restaurateurs porte
parole du mouvement restons ouverts
bonsoir à tous les trois merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous alors on a
bien compris en ce sont les variants
l'inquiétude numéro un du gouvernement
on rappelle quelques chiffres plus de
2000 patients par jour toucher désormais
par un variant olivier ferrand qui a
fait le point sur l'épidémie le premier
le ministre de la santé qui n'était pas
vraiment optimiste on écoute avant de
vous faire réagir
globalement le couvre-feu à 18h à une
efficacité probablement at il permis que
nous évitions de connaître la même vague
épidémique que nombre de nos voisins
mais à l'évidence cette efficacité
s'estompe et à l'évidence cela ne suffit
pas à faire reculer le virus je peux
vous citer des exemples d'hôpitaux qui
procède actuellement à des transferts de
patients de réanimation au sein d'une
région c'est le cas notamment de nice
qui est obligé de transférer des malades
parce qu'ils ont trop de malades qui
arrivent en service de réanimation
je vous parlais de la région grand est
de bourgogne franche comté ou des
hôpitaux font face à des fortes tensions
dans les service de réa dans les
services d'accueil des urgences et des
hôpitaux et nous ne sommes pas très loin
d'envisager à nouveau de procéder aux
premiers transferts de patients inter
régionaux pour soulager certaines
régions nous sommes presque à 60 %
d'occupation des lits de réanimation par
des patients atteints de corona virus
donc non la tension hospitalière elle
est réelle a plein de mauvaises
nouvelles à cela gabriella talent porte
parole du gouvernement qui rajoutait que
le maintien du cadre actuel paraissait
peu probable la majorité clairement nous
prépare psychologiquement un troisième
confinement cécile heures et là je ne
sais pas si la majorité très par cela
une chose est sûre c'est que moi dans
mon département dans ma circonscription
ça fait des jours où je
j'entends mes concitoyens m'appeler me
demander s'il va y avoir un troisième
confinement donc c'est véritablement un
sujet et comme le disait certaines
personnes interviewées dans votre
reportage
moi je sens monter une réelle angoisse
de la part de mes concitoyens s'il
devait y avoir un troisième continent
dont vous comprenez bien que dans ces
conditions le gouvernement et qu'ils
consultent énormément un pas seulement
le monde médical mais qui consulte
également les élus des élus locaux les
parlementaires les corps intermédiaires
va vraiment prendre une décision la plus
[Musique]
sale on ne pourra pas reculer
c'est ça que ces sacs importante pour
l'instant nous aussi on attend les le
discours du premier ministre donc la
semaine prochaine il nous a annoncé un
débat à l'assemblée nationale avec un
vote
donc ça veut dire en effet qui va y
avoir de nouveau des décisions
importantes à pro et ça on l'avait
justement compris stéphane manigold
ville les palau aussi le problème 1 il
ya le problème évidemment d'un
confinement craint par les français mais
aussi celui de de ne pas être prévenus à
temps parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya par
exemple beaucoup de parents qui
attendent pour organiser les vacances
scolaires c'est très compliqué on le
sait quand on travaille et qu'on a des
enfants
est-ce qu'on n'attend pas un petit peu
trop quand même le dernier moment on
attend oui trop dernier moment on nous
prend un peu pour des enfants et on est
dans le manque d'anticipation total le
présent république avait indiqué qu'elle
et 66 millions deux procureurs dont il
ya 66 millions d'êtres humains
d'individus qui travaillent qui sont
parents qui emmènent leurs enfants à
l'école et cette entreprise qui vivent
dans l'angoissé parce que chaque semaine
eh bien il ya des échéances
supplémentaire des dates qui n'arrivent
pas à des ouvertures qu'il n'arrive pas
et
c'est ce manque de lisibilité
aujourd'hui qui fait défaut aux 66
millions de français il y a une espèce
d'anxiété et là pour le coup est bien
vous faites pas votre travail pardon
madame la députée de vous le dire mais
et vous fait pas le job parce que les
français les françaises ont besoin
d'être rassurés ce ne sont pas des
enfants ils n'ont pas besoin de
câlinothérapie
ils ont besoin et bien d'avoir un cap
une orientation une définition d'une
politique de vaccination claire précise
et sans couac une accélération sur le
sujet vous avez des millions de
personnes qui ne travaillent pas
aujourd'hui alors oui ces personnes non
salariées sont protégés sont sont
rémunérés nos entreprises sortent à
peine le nez de l'eau pas la tête mais
le nez de l'eau la bouche reste toujours
sous l'eau et puis vous avez madame borg
pour reprendre et pour parler de nos
amis de la montagne qui a indiqué aux
saisonniers bien aux stations de ski de
recruter des salariés ce qu'ils ont fait
est bien le reste à charge il y est pas
parce que eh bien les saisonniers comme
vous le savez en montagne ils sont
hébergés
ils sont logés et c'est tout un pan de
l'économie qui en train de massacrer al
rien dialogue avec bercy faut souligner
il ya des regrets bruno le maire il ya
un dialogue à la carlingue lisait mais
je vais vous poser une question assez
directe madame la députée si demain à
l'assemblée nationale il y a un projet
de loi qui vous est présentée concernant
l'indemnisation au réel du préjudice
subi par les entreprises sans faute de
l'état dans le monde entier
il est un confinement est ce que vous
serez prêt à voter cette indemnisation
réel pour les entreprises parce que vous
nous créez de la dette aujourd'hui sans
qu'on soit en capacité de main de la
rembourser le prêt garanti par l'état
c'est un prêt et comme vous le savez
pour pouvoir un moment rembourser un
prêt et bien il faut qu'on gagne un tout
petit peu d'argent envoyés pour pouvoir
faire face à ses dépenses auxquelles
nous ne pourrons pas faire face donc ma
question est simple même les députés
est ce que si demain à l'assemblée
nationale vous ai présenté un projet de
loi visant à indemniser les entreprises
durablement frappé par cette crise est
fermé
par l'état est-ce que vous mettrez un
amendement qui qui va dans ce sens alors
on va laisser répondre cécile relax
rapidement avant de laisser aussi la
parole à jean frédéric poisson qui pour
l'instant n'a pas parlé cécile relax sur
la question clairement posée alors avant
de répondre ça fait sont clairement
posée deux remarques non d'anticipation
le problème aujourd'hui c'est que
comment vous voulez anticipées
lorsque il n'y a pas de visibilité alors
à moins d'avoir une boule de cristal
aux sons peux pas anticiper donc on est
obligé de prendre des décisions par
rapport à des chiffres et par rapport à
une situation
cette situation aujourd'hui on est en
train de voir qu'il y avait un plateau
que ce plateau augmente malgré le
confinement que ce plateau augmente
malgré les mesures et il va falloir
enrayer l'épidémie est en fait c'est une
course qui est en train de se passer
entre le variant même les variants
puisqu'aujourd'hui nous en sommes à
trois et la campagne de vaccination
là où vous dites également qu' il n'y a
pas de cap de fixer je suis désolé
monsieur le cap sur la politique
vaccinale
elle est très très bien fixée elle est
très claire depuis le mois de décembre
donc là dessus nous n'avons jamais
dérogé au calendrier vaccinal je dirais
même que par rapport aux annonces du
mois de décembre
nous sommes même en avance sur le
calendrier vaccinal qui avait été prévu
et qui a été présenté d'ailleurs devant
l'assemblée nationale par le premier
ministre donc là dessus je peux pas vous
laisser dire qu'il n'y a pas de cap
qu'il n'y a pas de visibilité
nous savons exactement où nous allons au
niveau du calendrier fixe à fixe et je
compte à votre dernière question il y a
juste un petit paradoxe dans ce que vous
dites c'est que d'un côté vous me
demander de voter un amendement pour une
même dénomination une indemnisation sur
l'économie et sur les entreprises et
d'un autre côté vous nous dites que la
dette elle plombe
si jamais vous nous demandez de voter
une indemnisation je sais ce que j'ai
noté une indemnisation coûtant pour
toutes les entreprises
ça veut dire que ça sera l'état qui
paiera et donc ça serait une
augmentation de la dette nationale dont
il va aujourd'hui oui on va on va donner
pardonnez moi on a compris en tout cas
voilà oc 3 européennes
on va laisser aussi répond de jean
frédéric poisson qui faisaient les gros
yeux en compte et écoutez madame la
députée s'exprimer sur l'anticipation
jean frédéric poisson cher à tous et
merci à notre invitation jeu il se
trouve que je sais un peu d'expérience
que de temps en temps être un député de
la majorité parlementaire ce n'est pas
facile il a visiblement ça se vérifie
j'étais fière je suis un de vos
confrères avec un des collègues du modem
riaa qui il était le pauvre dans un sale
état
les français ne peuvent pas entendre ça
cette espèce de supplice chinois de
torture qu'on nous inflige depuis deux
semaines trois semaines un mois il y
aura
iran t'il pas de confinement titre il
faut être confortablement installé dans
sa vie personnelle pour n'être pas
impactés par comment dire ces annonces à
répétition qui ne nous permettent jamais
ni de prévoir ni d'organiser quoi que ce
soit ne m'aiment pas simplement sur le
plan professionnel et pas simplement
comme quand on est comme c'est mon cas
d'ailleurs un travailleur indépendant ou
en chef de pied d'entreprises comme
c'est le cas de lui coller aux
restaurateurs qui est avec nous donc sur
le plan de la communication la gestion
de cette aide est une catastrophe
une pure catastrophe quand j'entends
madame le député chars collègues je suis
désolé de vous le dire que vous êtes en
avance sur les annonces faites sur grax
enfin hier il y avait six mille
personnes vaccinées en france vous
entendez 6000 personnes ont reculé de 12
vous ne pouvez pas décemment oui un
million de personnes ont reçu la
première dose et sur 1 2 million si
milan suit les deux de nos fils du
ministère de la santé
donc à ce rythme là il faudra à peu près
peut-être trois siècles et demi pour
vacciner l'ensemble des français ça
n'est pas sérieux
il est par ailleurs j'entends que les
interdictions faites aux médecins
comment dire de de traiter de d'admirer
les traitements dont ils ont prouvé
l'efficacité dans leur cabinet tout cela
continue d'être ennuyés donc je dis
simplement sur le plan de la
communication cette gestion est une
catastrophe sur le plan de la stratégie
de santé publique cette gestion de crise
est une catastrophe
et c'est pourquoi je dis que le
couvre-feu écoutez j'ai entendu le chien
entendu la ministre la santé dire que le
couvre-feu et est efficace dans des
endroits où il était impliqué 18 heures
madame le député vous habitez balle de
match je crois donc en ile-de-france
comme moi à quelques dizaines de
kilomètres de paris
vous avez vu 0 voitures sur les
autoroutes quand vous rentrez chez vous
à 18h bien sûr que non c'est une farce
il ya des centaines de milliers
transilien qu'ils ne respectaient pas le
couvre-feu
parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas faire
autrement et il ya des millions de
français des millions de français qui
sont dans cette situation de ne pas être
en capacité
simplement parce qu'ils veulent sur vire
de respecter les consignes idiote que le
gouvernement envoie à l'ensemble de la
population du troisième confirmer ça va
exploser je vous le dis et si ça
n'explose pas dans la rue ce qui n'est
pas monstrueux ça explosera dans la tête
des gens parce que on fabrique depuis le
mois de juin je suis le monde du travail
depuis longtemps et je parle avec les
organisations syndicales et
professionnelles depuis très longtemps
depuis le mois de mai
arte sur les conditions dans lesquelles
le télétravail pouvait bouleversé
esquinté psychologiquement les
travailleurs qui sont concernés donc ce
n'est pas une nouvelle ils se réveillent
maintenant dix ans à il ya peut-être une
crise psychologique qui nous a donné moi
j'en connais avec 300 points pour
avancer dans le débat pour rebondir
surtout sur ce que vous venez de dire
regardez ce sondage
cette idée voulez vous avez raison de 3e
confinement ne plaît pas beaucoup aux
français cet institut de sondage et la
bhl sur l'acceptation des français
depuis le début de la crise il ya
bientôt quinze ans c'est un petit peu la
dégringolade 93% des français étaient
favorables au premier confinement en
mars dernier 67 % lors du deuxième le 29
octobre dernier et seulement un français
sur deux aujourd'hui alors pour rebondir
sur ce que disait jean frédéric poisson
cécile est là qu est ce que vous
craignez à la majorité une révolte à
l'instar de ce qui se passe notamment
aux pays bas au danemark ou en espagne
est ce que l'exécutif est clairement
inquiet aujourd'hui
moi j'ai pas parlé pour l'exécutif
puisque je vous dis pas les marges
pourraient tourner là nous sommes alors
la mairie personnellement en tant que
député de la majorité
c'est ce que je disais dès le début et
c'est pour ça qu'avec monsieur poisson
là dessus on est d'accord parce que moi
j'entends bien aussi cette angoisse est
justement les retours de terrain que je
fais au gouvernement pour qu'il puisse
prendre sa décision
c'est que cette tension psychologique
cette angoisse elle est réelle et que en
effet je confirme que il y a aujourd'hui
le troisième complètement n'est pas
acceptée aujourd'hui par une grande
partie de la population et
particulièrement par les personnes qui
ont l'impression d'avoir déjà beaucoup
donné et particulièrement notre jeunesse
donc c'est no c'est mon boulot de
députés de faire remonter aussi des
informations qui qui qui qui sont la
réalité
après il faudra prendre les décisions et
on est là pour prendre des décisions les
meilleures possibles de manière à ce qu
un risque de crise sociale énorme comme
vous l'avez dit aussi avec des personnes
qui sont dans une situation
psychologique très très inconfortable et
il ne faudrait pas rajouter à une
situation sociale à une situation
sanitaire difficile
un problème de crise économique derrière
stéphane magnier goal c'est madame la
députée mesdames la députée lorsque
vous êtes exprimés vous m'avez vous
m'avez parlé comme un opposant politique
moi je suis chef d'entreprise j'ai un
collectif qui s'appelle restons ouverts
et ça fait des mois
madame la députée que nous appelons à
l'unité et que le gouvernement les élus
nous écoute parce que nous sommes force
de proposition et lorsque je vous
entends dire avec une forme de mépris
pardon j'ai pas de boule de cristal moi
non plus j'ai pas de boule de cristal
en revanche chez un chef d'entreprise et
diriger c'est prévoir et lorsque le 7
janvier j'annonce qu'il ya un troisième
confinement c'est pas parce que j'ai vu
dans une boule de cristal
c'est juste que hélas ce virus y sévit
dans le monde entier et j'observe
comment y circulent en allemagne comment
y circulent au royaume-uni et dirige et
c'est aussi prévoir est bien gouverné
madame la députée c'est aussi prévoir et
quand le 7 des 11 janvier
j'annonce le troisième le confinement à
l'anglais c'est parce que j'observe
quand le 24 septembre avait que votre
confrère sylvain maillard respectable
puisqu'il est chef d'entreprise en plus
députés que vous connaissez très bien
le 24 septembre j'annonce le deuxième
confinement non pas parce que j'ai une
boule de cristal mais parce que
simplement à nouveau ce sont des
statistiques et je sais lire des
statistiques et je lis quotidiennement
les rapports de santé publique france
donc ya pas besoin de boule de cristal
pour diriger une entreprise n'y a pas
deux en boule de cristal pour digérer
impayés il suffit simplement d'observer
ce qui se passe ailleurs et qu'ensemble
on s'écoute et qu'on arrête de se parler
comme des opposants y compris là pour
les opposants politiques c'est facile
parce que moi la politique l'a fait dans
les urnes quand je vote là aujourd'hui
je protège et j'essaie de protéger et
bercy vous m'avez pas entendu tout à
l'heure mais je le répète
merci est à nos côtés bruno le maire est
à nos côtés alain griset est à nos côtés
il nous soutient
mais moi je vous le dis il n'y a pas
qu'eux qui doivent nous soutenir les
députés et vous êtes dans un département
l'oise qui est lourdement touchée par
cette crise c'est beaucoup mais il faut
aller plus vite parce qu'on a encore
plusieurs idées avons fait réagir
clairement vont pour on compte ce
confinement et on donnera la parole à
jean ferrat eric poisson pour ou contre
ce troisième confinement serait
économiquement moralement absolument
contre scientifiquement je ne suis pas
un virologue
ça il appartient aux professionnels de
santé d'établir les raisons de ce
confinement jeune frédéric poisson
justement pour vous faire réagir sur non
ces français qui semble être plutôt
contre en tout cas il y en a un sur deux
aujourd'hui vous vous appelez clairement
la désobéissance civile
oui je crois que nous sommes entrés dans
une période où à lire certains nombres
de deux circulaires ou de décret est
publié par le gouvernement sur le
rabotage de libertés fondamentales à
voir combien les mesures restrictives de
nos libertés y compris d'ailleurs la
liberté d'entreprendre et de travailler
qui est ô combien impact est aujourd'hui
de manière parfaitement disproportionnée
par rapport
pas forcément par rapport à la situation
sanitaire mais par rapport à ce qu'on
pourrait faire de manière différente
la perspective de voir que tous les
français seraient nouveau confinés chez
eux est quelque chose qui me paraît
relever de l'oppression pure et simple
j'ajoute que ce n'est pas notre débat
d'aujourd'hui mais quand je vois qu
arrive sur le bureau du conseil d'état
puis les gouvernements des décrets
concernant le fils le fichage sur les
questions de localisation ou encore des
restrictions de liberté de circuler de
culte et cetera je me dis que petit à
petit nous entraîneront un système à
cause de la situation sanitaire très
disproportionnée en matière de liberté
donc pour moi qu'il te précise et quand
le système et au classique quand par
ailleurs on sait bien il y aurait une
autre façon de procéder sur le plan
médical et scientifique et ben moi je
suis comme monsieur bahreïn je ne suis
pas médecin mais j'ai l'habitude
d'essayer d'écouté comme vous d'ailleurs
ne s'en doute l'ensemble des opinions
qui circulent et je suis très frappé de
voir le nombre de médecins qui lisent
mais ne craignez pas une saturation des
lits de réanimation nous savons comment
traiter la queue vide en dames et donc
arrêter de dire que la stratégie
vaccinale unique est le remède absolu ça
n'est pas vrai si effectivement il y a
cette capacité de traitement que des
médecins ont mise au point qui
fonctionne qui guérissent des passions
si effectivement on s'est impliqué dans
tous les établissements de restauration
de france et de navarre des risques
sanitaires d'étape sur deux on a fait ça
comment dire pendant les périodes qui de
l'automne et tous les restaurateurs que
je connais ont appliqué sa très
tranquillement et il a été parfaitement
montré que ce n'est pas les restaurants
qui sont à l'origine de la remontée de
l'épidémie
il n'y a pas de clusters de restauration
tout ça n'existe pas l'histoire des
restaurateurs que vous pouvez parler
exactement c'est tout à fait ça donc si
vous voulez on sait bien les français
sont grands ils sont responsables si
vous leur est donné le soin là où ils
sont de regarder les choses de manière
intelligente de manière respectueuse ils
font attention à leur propre santé parce
qu'ils sont pas fous ils n'agissent
traduit moi de vous couper j'aime pas ça
mais c'est vrai que chacun s'exprime
très long moment du combat on a du mal à
faire avancer les idées parce que je
voudrais qu'on termine ce débat avec la
fin de la mission qu vide à l'assemblée
nationale je vais vous redonner la
parole mais partent parler peut-être
plus rapidement tous les trois s'il vous
plaît la mission commis de l'assemblée
nationale qui a été dissous décision
annoncée hier et qui a provoqué la
colère des députés de l'opposition avant
de vous faire agir écouter celle de jean
luc mélenchon damien abad et olivier
faur la mission parlementaire de suivi
de la crise qu vide est arbitrairement
dissous deux privant le parlement de son
pouvoir de contrôle
c'est une trahison démocratique nous
sommes en train d'assister à
l'enterrement de première classe de la
mission d'information sur la corrida
l'assemblée nationale et ceci en pleine
crise sanitaire
c'est un naufrage démocratique
totalement surréaliste alors que le
sénat va lancer la sienne
ici elle s'arrête scandaleux en marche
dissous la commission denquête de
l'assemblée nationale sur la gestion de
la crise sanitaire par le gouvernement
contre l'avis de toute l'opposition
macron et ses ministres ont peur
d'assumer publiquement leur politique
hasardeuse maladresse trois minutes on
va essayer de se distribuer la parole
chacun cécile relax votre réaction une
trahison démocratique
non ce sont les règles c'est à dire que
une mission parlementaire ces six mois
et il ya justement eu un rapport qui a
été émis quelle est la part de monsieur
sottise mon collègue julien borowitz
qu'était le président justement de cette
mission parlementaire dont classe ne
s'est pas un déni de démocratie
c'est que c'est simplement les
simplification du fonctionnement de
l'assemblée nationale donc la mission
parlementaire elle elle a eu son temps
donc par contre tous les collègues de
l'opposition s'ils le veulent ils
peuvent toujours demander une commission
d'enquêté n'y a aucun souci
c'est ce qu'on appelle le droit de
tirage nous sommes en 2020
1 donc si jamais que ce soit monsieur
mélenchon monsieur forme sur la bad qui
vole de nouveau ouvrir une commission
enquête sur ce sujet ils le peuvent tout
à fait donc il n'y a aucun déni
démocratique
stéphane manigold le citoyen que vous
êtes attendait quelque chose de cette
commission
ça c'est de la politique d'ossages
délaisse discutent entre eux par contre
je vais juste l'utiliser une seconde de
mon temps de parole pour dire que 1 au
collectif nous ne sommes pas pour
l'insérer l'insurrection
c'est dire est citoyenne ou je ne sais
quoi ça c'est non et 2 concernant je
dirais les le confinement j'ai juste
apporter un invariable
oui pour un confinement si le président
de la république fixe un cap avec une
vision claire et un objectif non si
c'est pour nous laisse à la maison
regarder netflix et nous tourner les
pouces
le mot de la fin pour vous jean frédéric
poisson
monsieur lamy la désobéissance civile ça
n'est pas leur insurrection
la désobéissance civile elle est un
droit constitutionnel reconnu par le
conseil constitutionnel
il ya même eu madame le député vous
vérifierez vous même reconnu par le
conseil constitutionnel manière tout à
fait formels il est le moyen qui est
donnée au peuple de dire au pouvoir
exécutif qui ne l'entend pas il doit
changer de trajectoire ne s'agit pas
d'aller cassé des abribus
il s'agit d'aller soutenir en
désobéissant réglementation idiote de
soutenir les gens qui désobéissent
réglementation idiote je répète j ai
déjà des marines est un virus qui tue
oui non oui il ya bien l'institut oui
d'accord
enfin il ya aussi des gens qui meurent
et des restaurateurs qui ferme qui
n'ouvriront pas et je ne parle pas de
tous les autres commerces des éléments
défendez pas messieurs je vous le faites
de manière professionnelle moi je le
fais des responsabilités politiques
chacun son boulot comme vous l'avez très
bien dit mais c'était simplement si les
gens comme moi ne vont pas soutenir des
restaurateurs qui ouvre le 1er février
les restaurants fermés c'est tout ce que
je dis et si on fait pas parler dans des
commerces
restaurateur vosgien qui s'est suicidé
parce qu'il a pris une fermeture
administrative
il faut quand même et indiqué qu'ils
s'exposent à de lourdes sanctions
donc moi de toute façon des restaurants
sont déjà ouverts j'ai pas attendu le
1er février parce qu'on est autorisée à
faire de click and collect ou simplement
ce que je ne veux pas c'est que les
restaurants ouvrent avec des clients à
table moi je n'appelle pas à de la
désobéissance qui générerait des drames
bien pire qu'ils le sont déjà
actuellement
merci à tous les trois c'est sillery
laquelle jean frédéric poisson et
stéphane manigold avoir été avec nous en
direct